tax card tax cut tax cuts that is a tax
which will not go up one big issue for
some national insurance top of the list
of tax cuts
i didn't vote for the national insurance
right and others are now joining me on
that platform and i'm very pleased to
see it because what we need is not a tax
on growth but a growing economy good
morning
sajid javid is also pledging to axe the
tax rise a change brought in to fund
health services that he backed in april
when he was health secretary and this
levy
the way it's being raised is the the top
15 percent of earners will pay almost 50
percent and i think it's the right way
to do this today a different tune my job
as health secretary was to make sure
that we had the resources to meet the
promises we made on health care and
social care my job was not to decide how
to raise it and that is a tough decision
i respect that but the current fiscal
situation i believe that we can afford
to scrap the levy and still fund all of
that increase that was promised
another former health secretary while
promising business tax cuts is not going
as far i'm not promising uh some of the
tax cuts that other people have promised
i do think the nhs needs the 12 billion
a year
that we're getting from the health and
social care levy much as i dislike
having to pay it
arguments about tax are never hard to
find in westminster but there's a reason
why they're flaring now
this tax bidding war is being driven by
the big irony in conservative party
politics right now the current
government has put up the tax burden to
its highest level in over 70 years while
simultaneously claiming it's a
tax-cutting party the candidates right
now are trying to square that circle but
what might be popular for tory mps and
members might be less palatable for
others
at a time of rising prices pay restraint
and nhs backlogs experts say there needs
to be clarity on how tax cuts may impact
government spending it is
quite something to be focusing on the
tax cuts rather than potential spending
increases and i guess that's a very
strong political message that's coming
out of this leadership election but i
think the key here is if you are going
to be promising tax cuts you really do
need to be clear what it is that you're
intending to change which means that you
can deliver the public services that you
say you're going to deliver with less
money
one leadership contender saying he would
make savings to fund tax cuts i would
certainly look to reduce the cost of
doing government i think that's really
important civil servants well in in
you'd partly do this through attrition
of course and sacking sounds very very
very harsh but you you know you simply
stop employing people in in post you
allow the thing to come down with a
crowded field senior tories will meet
tomorrow to set the timetable for this
leadership election a wide open race
today focused on a narrow set of issues
rob powell sky news in westminster